any fire is dangerous but when
hydrocarbon jet fuels involved the
chance of disaster is much higher
airports are particularly vulnerable to
these kinds of dangerous blazes so
instead of regular fire trucks they need
something faster and more versatile this
is where our front scanner
this is a striker one of the largest ARF
vehicles and production
made by military contractor Oshkosh
there are more than 1,100 strikers in
operation around the world each one can
cost over a million dollars the Stryker
is a souped-up firetruck with some
special features that make it more than
just a water truck on wheels this nozzle
a piercing hose that bores through a
burning plane's fuselage and douses the
inside tack for independent suspension
originally designed for Oshkosh is
military trucks tack bore gives each
wheel up to 16 inches of travel allowing
this vehicle to drive over almost any
terrain
acceleration this eighty-seven thousand
pound striker can accelerate from zero
to fifty miles per hour in just 35
seconds which is especially important
when fighting fast burning hydrocarbon
fires and these vehicles aren't just
helpful in an emergency they're required
the FAA mandates that all airports with
passenger flights have ARF trucks on
standby